i expect that many of you viewers
already know quite a bit about our cat
sassy and her unfortunate death
about two months ago from my social
media posts or the things that i've
written about her here they are said in
other
videos and this was her room originally
it was our
room for the kids to to spend time in
when they were visiting here but in
covid times sassy basically took it over
took over this bunk bed towards the end
we got her this cat bed that she
loved and this blanket and we still keep
it in here
so
in the past when our other animals
finally met their end and
mostly you know at a good ripe old age
i've done tribute videos and
you know with clips of
them doing their various things and
engaging in their typical
behaviors when it comes to sassy because
she lived so much longer than everybody
else 19 years in fact i have a ton of
footage and so
if you aren't really up for watching
about an hour's worth of stuff then
maybe this video
isn't for you but for me it's a great
way to
celebrate and reflect on
all the things that this little
animal was and before i you know i start
showing you stuff i'll just say this you
know i've had a lot of cats i've had a
lot of dogs a few other kinds of animals
over the course of my
lifetime but i've never
bonded as
deeply as i did with sassy she really
became
my companion and i became
her person we did so many things
together as you're going to see in the
clips yet to come
and you know i i do miss her quite a bit
it's like having a part of yourself
that you can't access but i also kind of
feel like
i can bring her to mind
anytime that i want to and
imagine or remember
what it was like picking her up or
talking with her and her talking back or
cuddling up together or any of the other
things that we did especially a lot here
in this room where she would sleep on
this little bed on the big bed and then
want me to sleep next to her as a matter
of fact sometimes she'd actually
call for it or gesture
for it and then you know when i laid
here she'd move my hands around to the
configuration that she wanted them in
but that's enough reminiscing right now
i just wanted to say a little bit before
i begin
this excursis into the
life of this
this wonderful cat who
is you know dearly missed but very
fondly remembered
so this is how we would start many of
our mornings you see sassy
going down the steps doing her little
bunny hop and
waiting for me you know i'm her person
so she wants to make sure that i'm
coming along properly and
this is probably from the last year that
she was alive so she's moving a little
bit
slowly you can notice too that she was
as the vet called it over
barbering on her back she she'd lick
some of the
um
hair off too much and so she's
bringing me along she knows exactly what
she wants to do
now we're on our eighth floor
of the building
our apartment and you notice all of her
stuff there she's got piles of catnip
and various toys
and
a hoof that belonged to one of the dogs
originally
and she's uh you know waiting to see
what what i'm going to do
so i'm giving her some more catnip there
and uh she's uh happy
about that and she'll hang out in her
little
place
with all of her
her precious things as we used to call
them around you know some of them are
just like feathers that i grabbed from
the ground at the park she's coming up
to me now and asking for
something um probably looking for a bit
of food or a snack or something along
those lines yep there there it is so we
have these dried
uh
snacks made from various
types of um
meat that she really got into we
actually got these
from uh my sister-in-law's cat who was
devouring
them as well and so you can see how
happy
sassy was
here in this place with us she's got all
the things that she wants she's got her
daddy there in the morning this was
our routine uh until she started
sleeping downstairs in which case it got
modified a little bit and
i would bring her out
just as well
and
now that she's eaten it she's ready for
some more i think
and
waiting
patiently
more or less patiently now she's going
to groom herself
that's the over grooming or barbering
that the vet was worried about for a
while we actually had to put her in
infant onesies
so that
she would not
pick out as much of that hair
as she had been
before but you notice she's you know
very alert very happy this is you know
when she's
probably 18 years old i'm guessing
so she's doing
quite well as a cat
she's in front of the the food bowl
and that's her her water
bowls
she used to steal the dog's food out of
the food bowl as i'll show you later on
but now she's going to
slowly laboriously get herself up
to
get a little drink see how she hunches
over and
she's you know taking care of herself we
got all of her cat food and
treats and stuff like that over there on
the side
waiting for her
and she takes her time getting a nice
leisurely drink
so here's an image of her doing
something that she did a lot in the
mornings which is get up on the
shelf in front of our massive picture
window
and you know watch the city um
i think she had a little bit of a
fascination with the people down below
and and you know
she liked the cars as well and so she'd
sit up there and just check things out
uh you notice her food stuff is up there
and here's her uh getting the zoomies up
in the bedroom and i think that's
actually amica the dog i think you can
see poking a little bit behind her but
she's
really quite agitated she's probably 17
at this time coming over to hang out by
me
and
get some pets and here's her playing
with the robot that we bought this robot
would dispense treats we originally got
it for both her and the dog amica but
sassy got into it and then you know it
would roll around and she would go after
it
quite great to see an old cat doing that
here's her in the sunlight now this is
in kingston where
she and i first met and where my uh that
time fiance then wife was living at the
time i moved up there and
sassy and i would uh along with the
other animals hang out quite a bit
she loved being in the sunlight and
here's her you know poking her face
around
she was probably
12 at the time that i'm recording this
maybe a little bit
older
this is back here in milwaukee she's got
her scratching post this is upstairs
and
she well it's not a scratching post it's
more of a ramp and later on she would
you actually use that ramp to help her
get up in bed
mr rope uh originally a toy that the dog
amica had brought from the streets and
then sassy gets into it this is what she
would do
in the morning when she was still pretty
spry she'd want to play
hey
and there she goes scratching that's
some from fresh catnip for her that i
picked
from the city
we have a walk-in closet that is full of
stuff and she loved to open up the doors
on the walk-in closet
then go inside and who knows what she
did you know
lounge
experiment play around with things
it's difficult to tell
but she liked to
spend time inside there and she'd always
act a little bit guilty
when
we'd catch her in the closet i think
because my wife had you know kind of
conveyed the idea she's not supposed to
be in the closet i didn't really uh mine
that much because she didn't do anything
wrong it's not like she you know made a
nest or peed or anything in the closet
but you know
she was a curious little girl and uh
here you see her
sort of carrying that out and then you
know
cleaning herself as she would do
sometimes when she was embarrassed
now here is sassy and her sister teensy
twinning as we called it teensy
unfortunately died when she was about 12
years old in kingston of uh
organ failure her liver went bad
but she and sassy were the sole
survivors from an apartment fire
in uh new york city and then my wife
took them in and then later on adopted
the two dogs as puppies
and uh so they were the oldest animals
sassy and teensy and you notice how much
they love to cuddle up together
teensy had a little bit more dark
markings than sassy did and the full
tail of course now you see here
they're not the only ones on the bed
there's somebody else oh teensy woke up
and so did sassy and uh
they're wondering what's going on why
are they being filmed
and
there's them again
um
they'd you know snooze together quite a
lot during the day
actually they'd curl up together at
night although
sassy and teensy also like to curl up
with the dogs and curl up with us people
as well
and there's there she is
that's teensy looking
and here's little sass
all nestled in
uh
snoring away oh there she goes she's
awake now as well and both little
sisters
checking us out you know teensy gives
side eye she always looked like she was
a little bit ticked off
sassy was
the much more
you know outgoing and sanguine one
teensy was more of a retiring
animal
and of course cleaning you know the
two sisters would hug and
clean each other sometimes that would
actually turn into
uh
cat fighting
especially if they'd had some catnip
that would get them all riled up but
here you see
teensy is quite content to let sassy
clean her ear
and cuddle up with her you know
two very
nice little sisters
that
would hang out teensy by the way was
larger than sassy she was named the
teensy cat when she was a kitten and she
got um
not an awful lot larger than sassy but
you know significantly
larger where you could tell that that
one was bigger than the other and
this is something that cats do you know
whether they're related or not but when
they're part of the same litter
and they've known each other their
entire lives notice how teensy's getting
into it she's just like you know
it's almost like a cat massage for her
right or a cat cleaning
sassy is going wild she really gets into
it
and i guess teensy's ear must be very
either attractive or in need of of
cleaning because she's digging in there
and uh doesn't appear to want to
ease up on it at all
but this is the sort of thing that we
would see them doing very frequently
together
um sometimes it would be
sassy doing the cleaning sometimes it's
teensy look at that cute face uh this
teensy
rests in it and and now she's you know
waking up just a little bit
um
boy sassy just won't let that ear alone
now teensies had enough
and here we go back to the other one
so we'll see what happens uh how long
teensy is gonna gonna go for this sassy
is just licking away and now is she done
pretty close
now they'll
hang out together oop here we go start
up again
and uh teensy's just gonna lay there and
put up with it
uh
somebody's gotta do the cleaning around
here i suppose
but that's that's pretty cute what we
see them doing there
you can tell that they they really enjoy
their time together
now sassy's like putting her back into
it
and here's another one now you see
teensy is getting into the the cleaning
part oh sassy is doing it as well and
now they're
teensy's looking over at me
you know
teensy had such big eyes too
uh you can tell that they're sisters but
they they definitely each had their own
look and even their own walk sassy was
missing
half of her tail and it gave her what my
wife calls it walking hard in the yard
kind of stance and
walk that's more like i don't like a
bulldog or something like that
but these two really really did love and
care about each other um teensy was much
more retiring much more
introverted she didn't like to go
outside
um she wasn't as curious about stuff
though she did love to play and
especially with like pens and pencils
and
sticks and things like that and she was
quite a cuddler as well
so here's the sisters again together
i know i'm showing you an awful lot of
this but i think it's you know it's
important to think about
how these two
lived well at least the all of teensy's
life and the first two-thirds almost of
sassy's life together and then look at
this there's a there's magnus on the bed
with both of the cats uh
he almost looks like he's been caught
doing something and then here's amica
they all would hang out on the bed
together you know uh as a matter of fact
sometimes sassy would curl up with
magnus and teensy with amica they each
had their favorites
and there's sassy looking at me as i'm
checking things out she's quite content
to
lay there with teensy who's curled up
with her
and uh
oh there's teensy now she's awake
she wants to know what's going on both
of these beautiful sisters and their
adoptive
dog brother and sister as well
and here's
sassy with amica
we had these things that we bought
called yogi bows
and boy did the dogs and cats love to
lay on them they're originally for us
humans but they got claimed very very
quickly and so you notice that amica is
like cleaning herself but every once in
a while she's going to bump sassy
sassy was pretty cool about that sort of
stuff she liked hanging out with
both of the dogs
and now here is sassy also on a yogi bow
with magnus both of them basically doing
the same thing cleaning their bodies
and
sassy a little bit more thoroughly
perhaps than magnus but this is what
they would do as well they just hang out
and
you know snooze and
make noises every once in a while cuddle
up occasionally get up to get a drink of
water and then come back
and
lay down together
sassy liked to go outside quite a bit
and this is from
fairly early on this is kingston so
she's
going in the uh garden going around it
you notice that tale that i was talking
about and how she kind of walks
in a very distinctive
way sort of you know sort of like a i
used to call her grounder pounder you
know she was a bit of a bruiser and
so she's making everything her own
including the uh
irises there that we see growing in our
little garden the rocks are hers
and the
fence is hers and everything belongs to
sassy and
she um
she became quite bold it took a little
while to get her used to going out in
the yard
with me and then after she realized how
much
enjoyment she could have out there
here she is again
this is at
andy's mom's place in brookfield and we
take her out there she loved those
sticks
that would fall and she's
kind of wandering around talking a
little bit
wants to uh
hang out and um
probably moving towards the the car
which she might try to go under but
she's you know i'm i'm her dad so she
wants to be by me to know that it's it's
safe she would use me as sort of like a
safe place and then venture out you know
because she knew that if there was
anything bad i'd pick her up and put her
on my shoulder right away
and here she is same place uh checking
things out if you like to go into the
foliage there she's
going underneath the hostas and then
she's
taking a pee
um you know
which is not good for the plants but
it's not going to kill them either
and she uh you know
wanders around
there's still some like water on the
leaves probably some dew
and now she's venturing back out into
the yard
following along with with me
back out onto the driveway
and here she's walking up the path to
the house
meowing you know from time to time and
looking around checking things out
she knows what a door is
she kind of wants to go in
figures out that
nobody's going to let her in
now what what is she going to do
well you may as well explore some more
so
she's going to check out the pots and
the hose and the
cedars or junipers whatever kind of bush
those are that are out in the
front yard and
you know she'll talk a bit from time to
time
um she loves hanging out there at her
grandmother's place
and uh
andy's mom really liked having sassy out
there
as well
such a good cat
you know
and you know keep in mind again that
this is
in the
later years of her life she's still
pretty spry at 16 17 18 19. this is
probably be
when she was either 17 or
18.
and you know
she's pretty confident she doesn't need
to be too clingy
she's
going to explore
check out the whole yard um see if she
can you know smell some chipmunks or
mice or
little birds or anything like that
and
there she is
what are you doing
there she goes
now she's
coming over by me
and uh moving past into the
big girl
not sure what kind of bush that is but
you know this was kind of skulking
around
checking everything out
uh she really loved
being in these sorts of outside
environments
and i would take her as often as i could
to places like the park or the deck or
out here
um she really enjoyed being out and
about with the people
such a
majorly social cat
um
all the way to the the very end
here she is uh out by all the logs that
had been cut and then basically went to
to to seed um they weren't being used
for fires and she she liked that and
she's wandering around the yard some
more
um checking everything out
and
she's uh
she's gonna start making a break for the
house before
too long let's see her do that there
there she goes she's on the prowl
looking around
going over by her dad
and then
she changes her mind where are we going
now well
we'll go
over here by
the bushes oh those are lilacs um uh
that she's
playing around and now
some of them quite small some of them
larger
and uh
yeah she gets into it
she wanders around a bit more
she's going to see where this
this goes
more lilacs there that she's
pedaling around in
[Music]
and
just hanging out
just checking things out
and then she'll
ease herself down
into a nice
position where she can just like keep an
eye on everything
and take it easy
here's us some more
she's uh
trying to get back to the car
so i move her out into the grass and
then she's you know sniffing it
she doesn't eat much grass
and
there we go that's me and her
she goes kind of limp when she gets
picked up right
she's not quite sure what we're doing
and then
she likes it when i
give her a spot to
to hide in
she loved to snooze a lot as well
here's her on
the dog beds piled up in her room she
she had a tendency to claim things that
were originally for the dogs for herself
and you can hear her snoozing a bit
here's her again
her snores tend to be a little bit loud
in part because we think of the in smoke
inhalation damage
not that other cats and dogs don't snore
but sassy had quite a distinctive one
a little wheeze
this is on one of her favorite blankets
oh and you see her sitting on her dish
that she would turn over
and then that's mousy next to her her
special toy
here's her again same blanket on the dog
beds again mousy is by her her butt
and here's her in the
sunlight snoozing away this is on the
bed i think the big bed
[Music]
yeah those are our brown pillows
no gray pillows rather that she's curled
up with
and another one of her
deep sleeping you can see the deep
breathing that she's doing she like to
curl up in that position
sort of like it always reminds me of a
bunny
you know those big long back paws
sticking out her face there
she's wondering what's going on
why have i disturbed her sleep
can't she get back to sleep
or is the daddy gonna keep bothering her
with his phone
she would know when she's being recorded
too
she wasn't
super big on that
this is one of her favorite places to
take a nap in the day the big bed that
my wife and i used and in which sassy
would typically sleep next to me during
the night
when our dogs were still
spry enough they would sleep in the bed
uh quite often as well
good thing it's a king size bed
and here's her curling up
in that bed
you know she she would use the pillows
to like make a little
nest almost for herself
all curled up on herself this time you
know that one foot
you didn't hear me come in did you
how's the
she would sometimes get up in the bed
and then
try to get me to lay down next to her
she had a lot of different ways of doing
that meowing
moving around kind of like gesturing
with her eyes
she's always ready for some pets though
so look at she's stretching out with her
her back legs as i do that
yeah she was
such a
affectionate girl
and here's her
back in the same
more or less place
uh there's one of her comforters and
got pillows and she's
cleaning that paw oh
and a yawn
i have quite a few good pictures of her
yawning away
these are also dog beds that we had
purchased which again sassy took over
for her own
this may be after the dogs were
gone or it might have been while the
dogs were still around
she's looking for some
some pets and affection
this is the bed in the kid's room it's a
bunk bed and she would often
in the daytime
uh on the eighth floor
curl up in this bed
eventually this would be the the place
where she would spend her nights when
she was
no longer able to get up the stairs and
down the stairs and and when she would
just you know want to settle in here and
that was really
about i would say
the last
five months of her life
she loved that bed eventually we had
another bed
that we put on top of it a little pink
cat bed which she also loved as well
you know she's doing that
deep heavy breathing
she also like to go for rides and this
is us um she's in my arms
hanging out as we
get ready to go to i think the vet
now she's gonna crawl in the back
and there she is
uh this may or may not have been from
the same ride she'd like to go in the
back seat and check things out and uh
you're gonna see her start moving around
in just a bit
here she is you know fairly content
and sassy went on rides with us all over
the place out to brookfield to andy's
mom's place where the vet also was
she made it on a
cross-country trip with me she rode in
the
truck the penske truck that we we used
for moving our stuff and then we had a
breakdown we had to transfer to a
different truck
yeah she uh she actually went up to
green bay with us for a packers game
obviously she didn't go into the game
itself but she stayed in the hotel
uh we brought up her little
bed and
various stuff and she enjoyed it here
she is there we go she's checking it out
in the car
you know
she like being down on the floor
and uh
she also like looking out the window as
well watching the
cars and the landscape
there's my big girl
there we go
what is it mitten
now she's gonna make my wife's purse her
own mitten
you want to take your medicine now
not quite sure what's in the bag
she's like that's when i get the treats
but this is how she would ride along you
know she'd move around a bit
check to check out different things
very cool little cat
so much personality packed into that
little body
now
she loved to eat
sometimes she would lose weight and
stuff like that uh sometimes she would
go off of food but she was actually a
pretty good eater this is more of that
dried food
she really loved that stuff and it came
in different flavors beef and
um dog and
i think salmon and all sorts of
interesting
flavors for for cats
boy she was really a cat who loved beef
and
this stuff she would just
break apart and chew it all up and then
you know go drink some water because
it's it's dried so it's it gets a little
parched
a little bit of a messy eater too
here she is uh in a bed and
there were all these like pastes that
are made by different manufacturers and
these would be treats for her towards
the end she was more or less eating just
those sorts of things in broth but these
are good treats for her and she'd lick
away at them she really i mean she'd get
up for for this stuff if she knew that
you were opening up a package she'd find
you and crowd around you she really
enjoyed it quite a lot
and uh
it's pretty thorough there's not going
to be much
of that left
in that uh
that little uh not going to stop huh
cat bowl once she's done with it
here's another kind of paste this one's
kind of gross looking
but she was into that kind of reminds me
of another thing that she used to love
to eat which is uh brown schweiger or
liver sausage
which we would get on occasion and you
know she'd want a bit of it and uh it
was a way to also get her to take her
pills sometimes rapid and brown
schweiger this one is just some sort of
paste that i'm not sure
what flavor it is but we can you can
tell she's in the uh kid's bedroom
and
lapping it up
now this one is really funny this is a
bone this is a ham bone
and
she is
wild about it this became her possession
she would not let you take it away from
her
uh or if you did she would figure out
where you put it because she wanted that
that stuff or maybe this is turkey yeah
actually i think i'm wrong i think this
is a
part of a turkey
but boy did she she loved that sort of
stuff
and when i would make tuna casserole or
other things with that she wanted to be
offered the tins so she could get the
little bit of meat that clung to it and
the juice look at look at the intent
expression on her face
she is so into that and she would like
push these tins around
you know getting every little bit of it
off of her
whiskers afterwards
uh one of her favorite things to
chow down on
look at how she gets her whole face in
there
and now let's see about the other one
that other ones the first one is cashed
out let's get to the second one
you know
quite a treat for her
that was one thing we could count on is
whatever we
fed her
she would
she would eat it you know
within reason of course there were some
things of course that she didn't like
but
i was going back and forth
still got a third one in reserve there
too
and now she's done
you notice she's limping there
and we'd also get these uh uh chicken
breast things from pasco and uh you love
those too same sort of deal a little bit
bigger so easier to get her face
smashed down inside there and eat it all
up
you know she's
she's going at it again she's not gonna
let any of that stuff go to waste
what a fun little cat she was
[Music]
she's got her little feathers behind her
her toys
[Music]
really likes eating that chicken doesn't
she
[Music]
she's got some of it on her eyebrows
she could be a bit of a sloppy eater as
well you can see some of the catnip on
the floor
just past those chicken things i get her
fresh catnip and
she'd really enjoy that
here's her having a little drink
dogs and and she used the same bowls
they're all one big happy family until
she was the only one left
this may well be from
from that time
you were a thirsty girl weren't you
what do you think
what do you think
that's one of her toys on the ground
made from a ribbon and
some sort of top oh here she's getting
some dog food now what was some kibble
she loved what do you think dogs food
and here's her taking her
morning
bites of my
bagel with with cream cheese she liked
to have some of the cream cheese
and
sometimes you know like if there's
the cream cheese was done and the
wrapper was there i'd let her lick the
wrapper as well but she liked in the
morning to have a little bit of my food
and i didn't begrudge it to her
here's her going after my wife's uh
waffles
eating the butter you're eating my mom
she was pretty bold she would just like
you know jump up on you don't you care
yeah start you know pushing you out of
the way you don't care you use my food
if there was something that she thought
she should have here's me uh she's going
after my charcuterie plate i tossed a
bit to the dog and now she's eating my
turkey this is while we're watching the
packers game
um
look at her
eat so much of it
here's another bagel
laying on the bed
in the morning
she likes to be offered that good
you like the cream cheese huh
occasionally she would eat the bagel as
well you know i think because it was
crunchy but the cream cheese was really
what she had enough like the most
and now i have the rest burp it out with
some pets
here's her this is towards the end but
you can tell how emaciated she's become
and that she's not cleaning herself we
had to start using wipes and she is
drinking
broth that is um
comes in these these containers
it's nutrient rich and calorie rich and
she would drink the broth um
till the
very last day
um this is probably
two days before she dies
and uh you can tell she's
not looking that great
here's her
with amica
after magnus died in 2018 she and amica
were the only animals left and they
spent a lot of time together
you notice she's
curling up on the yogi bow
in the crook of amica's legs
uh while amica kind of tries to clean
herself but is actually cleaning the
yogi but more than herself
and here's sassy cleaning i mean
taking care of her
uh
as amica snoozes
isn't that
funny to see this
cat who's one-tenth not even one-tenth
of her size
cleaning this massive dog
taking care of her but amica was her
puppy
there's amica waking up now now here's
the two girls together
sassy's on one bed amik is on the other
bed
just hanging out
doing what they do
they love to be together even if they
weren't like curled up next to each
other
they like to be
not not just in the same room but
close by to each other
here's them eating kibble together now
this is dog food this is amica's dog
food and you can see sassy is ravenous
for it she would eat her own kibble
but she seemed to like the dog food
better and you know if you give it to
them in small quantities that's okay now
here's sassy doing something that really
disrupted stuff
my wife
caught her she would climb up
as you see
and in the middle of the night
and then later on boldly during the day
eat amica's food
amica did not like this it was one thing
to have it on the ground it was another
thing to have this cat coming over
and just straight out stealing your food
here she is over here what you doing
there says caught
that's the daytime
she's about to steal some of jamaica's
food and here comes amica who is going
to make sure that sassy knows that
that is for amica not for her let's see
look at mika giving her side eye
you know trying to make sure that sassy
knows that
this is her food
not cat food what do you think sassy
pants
pika pie
you don't have to eat it all
what do you think's that jessie's
waiting for a little handout
and here's her
snoozing again
lightly wheezing away
again curled up in the bed in the kids
bedroom which became sassy's room
sassy's bed
looks like she might be having a dream
you can see her little tail
here's her curled up
again with mousey kept safe underneath
the
uh food bowl
sassy put it like that
hey
do you have mousey there
you keeping mousey safe
oh that's nice
you're a nice girl
you keep your mousey nice and safe huh
yeah
yeah we'll leave him there for now okay
sound good
here's her and one of her favorite spots
you notice like the catnip on the ground
and
the sun that she can lay in she's got
some of her toys around her
including that bird that was for what we
call catfishing you know
we would play with it on a stick until
she got to the point where she
wasn't into that and she would stay
there
a good portion of the day while the the
sun was
out
and
she'd sleep and play with her toys have
some catnip get up get a drink
come back over there
one of her favorite places to be right
by our our bookshelf and not too far
from the dog's food as well
so she's giving herself a little bath
she really had quite a
great life for a cat
she didn't mind coving at all because it
meant that we were home all the time
and
she could just hang out with us
get whatever she wanted whenever she
wanted it
and there you go
this is a cat's life
there's our little pretty face
some more cleaning up in the bedroom
hanging out
another one of her favorite spots i mean
one of the cool things about this place
that we moved into
is that compared to where we were in
kingston where we had about you know 400
square feet but we did have an outside
yard
our apartment is on two levels has you
know multiple rooms lots of places for
her to
hang out in she could like go off on her
own take a nap be undisturbed unless i
came up and video recorded her like i am
doing here
and then whenever she wanted company she
would come seek us out you know
she really had the the best of all
worlds and if you think about like the
the amount of space
given her tiny little body i mean this
is we were basically living in a mansion
as far as a cat is concerned
here's her again doing the same thing
a little bit of a different lighting you
notice again she's like curled up inside
of the blankets
and comforters and pillows and stuff
like that she'd make herself almost like
a little nest
taking advantage of how we we had left
stuff and every once in a while you
catch her like pulling on stuff
or burying her her body parts underneath
the comforter
there she goes
hey sizzy pants
our pretty little girl
and same spot same activity
i have a lot of footage of her i would
come upstairs and like catch her
asleep or cleaning herself or doing you
know whatever it was that that she's
doing
and then i i video recorded it i'm
really glad that i did too in part
because you know if you're watching this
this far in
you realize how much
i did in fact record these aren't even
the photographs which you know i
probably have thousands of photographs
of sassy
doing all the different things that that
she did as a cat and i'm really glad
that i do have them because
it's nice to be able to
not just
bring her up in my mind's eye but to see
her
in what i've recorded in this digital
media
and there's a little sassy again giving
us a look
cleaning away
probably a little bit too aggressively
there you see her biting at the hairs
that's what she wasn't supposed to be
doing but at least it's not on the back
part where she did that you know
too much
little old girl
grooming away
yep
she she looks
she always wants to know what we're
doing as well
here's her almost in garfield pose you
know sometimes she would sit the way
that that garfield does on her haunches
uh
this is something she would do quite
often take that one
arm or paw and
put it way way
on her back so she could uh
get to some of the
areas that are a little bit tough to
reach i suppose she liked being brushed
as well
coming in real close
and here's her again there's her
beautiful little face
getting some pets
looks like i'm taking this like as a
basically a selfie as we're laying in
bed together
it must be quite a while ago given that
my
oh it's that was in kingston yeah
and this is in uh
kingston as well
she's just kind of
hanging out
about to fall asleep
opens her eyes again a little bit and
nodding off
here's her telling me it's time to get
up
she wants to come over by me in the bed
she's uh ready to maybe take her trip
downstairs you know i would start giving
her
rides when her legs started to get
getting a bit too weak to easily go down
the stairs or up the stairs
and she's uh prowling around you know
uh checking everything out
what a beautiful little girl she was
so loving
and yet sometimes so aggressive as well
look at that tail flip back and forth
she's ready to
ready to play or ready to quiet down and
go to sleep
this is one of my favorite clips
you could see her kind of
just reclining to being petted
look at that little
face
can't quite see her fangs her fangs got
quite long as she got older
but this is the face of a
happy cat
quite content
hanging out with her daddy
a little derpy look in there now you can
see one of the fangs right maybe both of
them
sticking out
she used to like to tooth us where she
run her fang against our
our hands
uh
you know one of her fangs is hidden by
her her lip but the other one is
sticking right out up
now she's gonna start cleaning a little
bit
that's our cute little sassy
this is the last of all the clips
for this video just
her curling up and reclining this is the
way i like to one of the many ways i
like to remember her
and i keep her in my heart
you